you already know what it is people's
hang a [__] Oh what is going on YouTube
you all have sent me your stories once
again and the people's hater is
officially back
that's right people I chose three
stories for defense so few people that
they are Nobuko we go joke back so hell
yeah let's get started
number one David I used to date this one
chick and a good buddy of mine told me
that he didn't like her see they never
really got along with each other and for
some reason they wanted me to stop
hanging out with one another the loyal
teacher of a long-lasting friendship
with my friend I chose to go with my
buddy instead of my girl well guess what
turns out the mother could jump on her
bones the moment Hoff broke up there s
mhm which either means shake my head or
shake my head
either way shits about to go down penis
mother jump ass [__] apparently you
never heard of bros before hold this
before chicks homies befo honeys well I
guess we all got secrets - then dump me
huh I got a secret - [__] I'm a North
Korean [__] and I'm below your ass ah
if you was hungry you should have let me
know yes snaggletooth hippo I would have
gladly given you my leftovers Oh what
was it she must have told you that we
never went that far did she
ah when you believe that trifling ass
huh you big you are put it in the mother
magellanic [__] I'm tired of those
waters and trust me the coochie will
shock your festive well that's how good
Pam I guess what even cuz I'm gonna have
to wannabe ass on this one remember I
told you that would never touch your
sister well she wasn't in a wheelchair
cuz she fell down some stairs you know
on food why would you even do that
you know had no scruples ghetto Expo and
you already know what my dirty son haha
[__] what these two things look like up
star be number two
David I'm thinking was months ago but my
so-called good friend had started
talking a lot of [__] behind my back and
telling all my damn secrets to everybody
but then of course she apologized weeks
later but she did it again every single
secret that I had invited in this [__]
she has told the whole world he was
talking [__] if you see one more buck
what I'm sweating over then imma build a
time machine go back and put your mama
on a roller coaster when she was playing
with your trifling ass yeah I said it is
one thing to go ahead and talk [__]
behind my back but [__] I tell my
secrets I didn't tell everybody that you
like to wax your hair so you hear me
Esther Ellen I didn't tell everybody who
thought you Jitsu was a Jewish mantra
logic dumbass I haven't told the boys in
school that you got more nipples than
you got titties you're not trying to be
you want to say sorry you want to say
sorry again all the time y'all saw me
ass to a chair and make you listen to
Rebecca Black for 30 days straight you
try the next hole [__] oh how to tie
your legs to a tree and make you watch
the whole Twilight series twice
[Music]
how dare you you mother your mouth out
serving the mother country and what were
you doing back home she was tossing
salad licking buttholes give another
dude money shots on the face flossing
her teeth with this pubic hair balls in
your mouth girl if this was the 15th
century you would have been circumcised
put that curse on me to present your
after job have you breastfeed all the
[__] inmates up in there you're
supposed to be in your bedroom taking
naked ass pictures of yourself sending
it over to your man through your mouth
your men can jack off and Iraq to your
ass instead of getting letters about you
him blowing all these other dude and you
said that he was cheating on you
how can he cheat on you in Iraq was he
banging other soldiers I don't think so
and on top of that you said that he was
cheating on you with strippers no are
there strippers in Iraq do you watch the
Discovery Channel you dumb [__] there
are no constrictors and Iraq there's
only sad just can terrorists and camels
and not three of those things you can
turn me on unless it was a bestiality
show but I'm pretty damn sure there
ain't no camel strip clubs over there
you'll find that can shoot some semen
out of this where's Hamilton Hamilton
ease you also suck at line came up with
the dumbest idea ever because there
ain't no [__] strippers in Iraq cause
if there were there wouldn't be a war
badge because titties solve all problems
but in this case your titties created a
problem by the way not all women are
[__] all just this one right here I
don't even you like using the word [__]
but thank heavens I've been saving it
for you [__] [__] means female dog and
guess what even my dog would have you
[__] so let that be a lesson to you and
please the dick out of the mouth
remember only you can prevent boys fires
[Music]
you regularly God man's balls and rub it
all over her face
you compounded a compound problem I hope
you know math because that was
multiplication addition Exponential's ^
ha [__]
so happy holidays I'd make sure don't
drink and drive Happy Thanksgiving